people don't calibrate their skill level
versus the market they delude themselves
into thinking that there's because they
feel good about themselves or smart or
whatever happened in their past that
gives them some confirmation bias they
they don't realize like well am I
actually a that could have a salesman or
that good of a communicator or that
could have a podcast oh so that could
have been ambassador like calibrate your
hits and misses I started doing this as
an investor I started looking at the
people I said no to and where did they
wind up so if you want to be actually
good at forecasting if you're good at as
an investor your misses are super
important what's your biggest miss
biggest miss gotta be one that's super
frustrating
well the biggest was a professional
investor was because I was gonna lead
the seed round for a great company and
they required me to join the board which
we typically you know don't do in a seed
round because obviously if I joined
every seed round investment I'd be on 40
boards not 15 it turns out that
company's done phenomenally well so we
haven't signed term sheet everything was
locked and loaded except they required
me to join the board and clock in
consultation with my partners we said I
couldn't do it it's now a several
billion dollar company did you say hey
it's Robin Hood oh my god so yeah so I
screwed up it's a six billion dollar
company old iPhone 20% yeah and Vlad
asked you to be on the boarding you did
do it
exactly so oh my good news Lawson is
you're gonna make good no but but I
didn't make the second miss and they
make the mistake a second time so
there's another opportunity I won't
quite name the company but boy years
later same sort situation emerged where
there's a cool interesting company that
was fairly competitive around the Robin
Hood wasn't back about it because no one
wanted to fund it no ground but this one
was fairly competitive and the only
condition was a how to join the board
and so this time I said yes yeah I
didn't even tell my partner's no game
not making the same god a mistake twice
in my life and turns out this company's
doing phenomenally well absolutely and
you can always go back to them and say
like listen I come off the board dial in
or I was like a new problem they make
other mistakes in life but I'm not
making the same mistake twice so I lost
sleep over Robin Hood for like a year
clearly
every single night so when the second
opportunity occurred obviously I didn't
know it was going to be as successful
but it will be as successful but I was
like this just feels like the same
decision again yeah and yes we're not
gonna own enough and yes we're not gonna
have enough money but yeah and in this
case there's another another but - which
is I knew the founder and I knew he's
gonna text me anyway for advice yeah
sounds like the incremental drag of
joining the board was gonna be small cuz
I was gonna be on the hook to advise him
anyway sometimes we'll just say yes and
then fortunately I did not say how many
board meetings here six or four this
one's probably six maybe should do this
four times and a quick phone call yeah
and I mean but it depends on the
velocity of the business and how fast
things change in the how difficult solve
the problems so there's no like a
formula but anyway I was like this time
absolutely yes I'm joining the board I
think this might be maybe the best
investment I've ever made and that's so
I'm very happy to say yes so you make
mistakes like that I think the biggest
mistake I made as an angel was more
because I had a day job meetings I just
was too busy to take so it was like I
don't think I made too many mistakes so
if I told someone know that I should
have said yes to other I did turn stripe
down we've had to go fix how to go fix
that years later with several seven
thousand like 100x multiple or something
or they said no - he may be more to
scale this mistake like we're talking
about mistakes that are on a personal
finance basis in the tens of millions of
dollars easily easily but the good news
is I was smart enough to a fix the
stripe mistake so I later watching his
slides up later investing be partly an
anecdote that I actually forgotten about
was even though I declined to invest the
time there was a very specific area of
help and favor I did for the company
that they really were able to benefit
from that I was sort of using my
connections and sort of social capital
to help them with which I totally forgot
about and then years later Patrick
remembered and reminded me of so I was
still able to be helpful to them even
though I didn't invest and so it turned
out to be a good thing anyway but yeah
that was it was a classic mistake my mom
corrected me actually my mom found out I
passed on stripe and she yelled at me
she's
oh my god this is like ridiculous like
stripe is so good how could you not
invest in it
Oh your mom's a developer running small
businesses and sales and she yelled at
me and then so when I finally invested
in strike like people knew the story
that you know I started rejected it
initially and you know the media was
looking for some edge and so I told the
story about my mom that sort of diffuses
its but he said Keith
it's your mother I mean onobu told me
this is wonderful Keith and you passed
exactly you schmuck yeah pretty much
that's the conversation with my mother
when she she I gave her a copy of my
book she's like I need to talk to you
today I'm like what is it mom I have the
manuscript I have edited it there are 17
f-bombs in here too
I don't want to give this book to my
friends and with these f-bombs okay I
taught you no f-bombs
like if you did if you said the word f
in the house oh yeah stand up and give
you a speech about the f-bomb